you may remember the school libraries
where many students discover popular
books like Charlotte's Web goosebumps or
Harry Potter 51 percent of kids say they
get their best book suggestions from
school librarians and teachers but more
and more schools do not have the
resources to pay for a full-time
librarian Dean Reynolds caught up with
an educator outside Chicago who's
crossing the country to share his love
of literature with as many kids as
possible
John Schumacher's job keeps him on the
road about 200 days out of the year and
this is what he does for a living
my job is til teachers and librarians
and principals and superintendents and
parents about the power of letting kids
read the books that they want to read
with a boundless enthusiasm giving a
drumroll please
this 35 year old librarian may be the
foremost advocate for school-age reading
in the country being in the library
being in this magical sacred place is
one of the most rewarding things we were
with him when he visited the Kendall
elementary school in Naperville Illinois
holy mackerel
where there are plenty of page-turners
and enthusiastic readers
what does reading do for you it
exercises the brain it fairs imagination
how old were you when you read your
first book probably five in kindergarten
really I think like one or two one or
two Wow
I have three copies to give a way
Schumacher's actual title is ambassador
of school libraries for Scholastic Book
Fairs and as such he tours schools all
over the country but even that broad
label is too narrow for his impact as
you're reading the book your heart is
growing as you're reading the book your
soul is billowing out I think reading is
the key to everything Veronica Donovan
teaches third grade here the library is
the heart of our school the students are
excited to go and without the library
I'm just not sure how a school could
function not every school is so lucky
according to a recent survey 39% of
school principals nationwide reported
not having a full-time librarian Carla
Hayden is the librarian of Congress many
schools are under severe fiscal
challenges and they have to make hard
decisions so that has affected many
school libraries it shouldn't be viewed
as a privilege it should be seen as a
right we cannot cut school libraries but
even if librarians are on hand it's
doubtful they'd be quite like mr.
Schumacher do you all love this smell
Vox I mean there is nothing there is
nothing better than the smell of books
over the years he's given away more best
smeller's than he can count would
somebody like this and you could take it
home and smell it
his work is so important because he's
giving inspiration to school librarians
it's not an oxymoron a rock star
librarian and last night I had so much
work to do
but I had to keep reading this book
Schumacher and reads about 800 to 1,000
books a year says that growing up he had
little use for the school library
because it was the place where he was
always being shushed I actually would
ask to go to the nurse a lot on library
day because I just I knew I was going to
be miserable when I got there have you
read this book before no it's one of my
favorites that changed when he spent
time as an educator and saw what a good
could do by putting a book into the
hands of a child we can put hope
directly into that child's hands we can
put love directly into that child's
hands that we can show them look you
have the power to make this world better
I love your enthusiasm there's three the
joy that came off of the kids that we
met today will carry me through the next
month and on to the next good book
everyone for CBS this morning Dean
Reynolds Naperville Illinois what a
great plus plus I love mr. Schumacher
saying reading a book your soul is
growing that's what a book should do
don't you guys remember when you got
your first library card well you've had
your name on it
oh I love this thing yeah the most
amazing difference between like today
and like when I was very young yeah as
access to books and information you know
because of the internet and other places
books can take you many many places here
grab Oh mr. Schumacher you're watching
CBS this morning we'll be right back